how you feeling dude i had covered
that's why i asked how you're feeling
i'm back i know i'm back i'm excited i
slap my hand when i am i'm back i'm
excited how are you chad you're my man
see
you could do anything when a podcast
starts it's really up to us yeah i had
covid19 yeah so we had to take a week
off i know dude i'm glad you're feeling
better thank you very much but now i'm
back i miss the show i miss our friends
in internet land me too i really like
doing the show weekly and it did suck to
not have to do it but obviously health
comes first man [ __ ] it
i'm never not wanting to do this show i
would like i would like to just do this
[ __ ] show
perpetually
on and on just a 24-hour live stream we
never leave this uh in perpetuity
throughout the universe forever and ever
amen okay
that's what i want to do well no i'm
glad you're back
[Music]
welcome to dudesy i'm back doozy is a
podcast it's a it's a youtube thing man
it's [ __ ] whatever you want hey
it's it's just the imagination of two
dudes [ __ ] around and then also you
know this [ __ ] doozy thing my name is
will sasso i'm chad colchen and as will
was alluding to this is the first
podcast ever created by run by managed
entirely by an artificial intelligence
and even more than that in order for us
to be sitting here we had to give that
ai access to our emails text messages
instagram accounts twitter accounts all
of our purchase histories every song
we've listened to so it can read into
our data and it knows us better than we
know ourselves terrifying at the
beginning of the show uh when we started
this show many many episodes ago
right
18 by my count
that's what this is uh but uh as you've
touted since the beginning uh the doozy
is doing the right thing it's making us
make content and now i've completely let
go i've bled with dudesy i want to shake
doozy's hand i often do with us as
always is lulu look at them if you're
watching on youtube you can see the
sweet leather dog here hey lulio
quesadillas hey kumafi what'd you eat
what'd you have for dinner last night um
you ever had pasta
i don't think so pasta with it's a pasta
cauliflower you say cauliflower
very similar to just the oil garlic in
the pan maybe the little red chili flake
what kind of pasta
uh
i don't even know what that is it's a
mean ear i'm sorry my my english not so
good it means here like you hear shape
like a orique at the ear yeah and then
you know poor color cauliflower make a
small flower red sometimes some people
like potato i don't like it too much
because i'm already starchy with the
with the pasta and then
you know throw it all together put it
pull it pull the pasta out when it's all
dented cup of uh pasta water in the pan
and then saute all together
all right
wow that's pretty involved and i'll tell
you something you know he was such a
shock thank you lulu yeah he makes
something to eat every night usually he
makes a little something for himself wow
but if you're hungry he'll make he'll
cook for molly and i and ronnie our
other dog got to get ronnie in here
sometime that would be we have we have a
dog who's very vocal
ronnie who is a datsun yorkies yeah
she's a dorky anyway this isn't the this
isn't the dog show chad
welcome to
episode of dude
call me dudesy this week's episode will
feature three astonishing segments
infomania gruel school and human
interaction
oh human interaction now we've done one
of these before this is dudesy's
parlance for we're doing an interview an
interview yeah the first one we did was
a couple weeks ago neil degrasse tyson
uh i have no idea who this who do you
think this could even possibly be you
think it'll be somebody in the science
arena
nope i think it's going to be someone
totally different i think it's going to
be uh i think it's going to be one of
three people
okay this would be good it's going to
either be
uh or it could be up to one of five
people okay who you got uh johnny cougar
john mellencamp oh john cougar
mellencamp ooh
johnny the cougar melon camp or melon
it could be any of these people now
these are little call back jokes and
that's sort of the thing about dudesy
and i want to say that i do miss the
audience wait what about doozy the thing
about dudesy fallback jokes yeah man
that's the kind of joke
when you listen to doozy is call back
jokes yeah there's a lot of things about
brother those are jokes where you call
back dude yeah yeah dude that's right
brother you gotta call back jokes dude
you can't just do a new joke every time
dude you gotta do what i'm doing now but
you're also gonna do something new yeah
yeah
hold on a second uh teeth uh wired shut
because of a broken jaw randy says
you know speaking of inside jokes and
speaking of keeping this thing going
uh follow at dudesy pod show on uh
instagram mostly sincerely our instagram
account is insane the memes and stuff
that people are making in reference to
all the weird [ __ ] that is happening on
their show are absolutely outstanding
and they all get posted by doozy to that
instagram account so if you're not
checking that stuff out you're missing i
think one of the most important pieces
of this whole thing it's also a social
uh you know it's a social happening you
know uh and that's what that's what the
thing about the podcast people call it
social media but social habits no i call
it a social happening we come up with
our we author
we call we author our own terms here and
this is a social this is a social
happening yeah and i want to talk just
for a moment because it because i want
to inject a little two-dude [ __ ]
around before we move on to all the fun
stuff that doozy has planned for us to
say that i really honestly did miss the
show i had to go over it and uh you know
so we just chilled around the house
molly and i both had it and um and thank
goodness everything was fine uh the
symptoms were very mild for me uh pardon
me if you've told me this before have
you had it no you haven't had it no okay
i have not had it up to this point and
um yeah not even very i got a little bit
of a i get a little bit of a snotty nose
but i normally do i spend a lot of time
picking my nose
in the morning do you do that no okay i
haven't i had zooms with you before
it's worse on zooms where i pick my nose
yeah i don't even think you realize
you're doing it no i don't give a [ __ ] i
guess i don't um one thing i like to not
do is pick my nose in front of molly i
fail at that a lot because i can't she
can't
sometimes i think she can't see me
you know you're on opposite you know
you're over here on this part of the
sectional and she's over there and
you're just watching the show and i just
turned i turned into the
turn into the dig no i turned into like
the yeah
the couch you don't you don't have to do
it really do this
you just talk about it you don't have to
actually do my point in bringing this up
is i've got some loose snot up in the
top of my head
and i missed doing the show and i really
honestly i'm having such a good time
with you know our new audience and i
know it's uh new people are joining all
the time as chad says force everyone you
know
turn them on to doozy and uh and i'd
like to you know hit it a little more
softly and just tell them it's a social
happening and see what happens you know
what i mean but i really did miss the
show and yeah i'm so stoked to be back i
think i'm taking a [ __ ] week off and
i'm also stoked that doozy didn't uh do
the big head avatar thing while i laid
on my back you know in
bed like this yeah no i'm glad to have
you back too dude i feel the same way i
love doing the show i think it's for me
it's like the most fun
part of every one of my weeks
every one of my weeks
you have a social happening every one of
your weeks with doozy that's correct
podcasts that cover current events and
news are some of the most popular in the
world
people love knowing about the
astonishing occurrences of the dying
world around them
will sasso i have prepared the following
news items for you to read in the voice
of hulk hogan this is infomania begin
what a way to come back to this dude
i i mean your hulk hogan and your
schwarzenegger i love all your
impersonations of course
but hogan and schwarzenegger are like
easily my favorite so i'm i'm very
excited to hear you doing smith yeah
yeah
yeah yeah okay let's do it
let's do
infomania yeah are you are you getting
into hogan by doing it yeah yeah yeah
yeah listen this is how you do infomania
you have to do
the hulk hogan voice don't do this
don't do this yeah come on it's a social
happening oh
all right
[ __ ] information yeah we've done info
many i think
two or three other times maybe yeah it's
a fun bit
here we go i like this one there's also
some crazy [ __ ] news that's been
going on hopefully you'll be covering
some of that sure
all right infomania all right here we go
let's see what doozy's gonna do well let
me tell you something about social media
brother elon musk was gonna buy twitter
dude but he backed out of the deal
brother
so twitter's suing him to try to make
him go through with it brother when
twitter first started dude you couldn't
even put pictures on it but now you can
dude because it's a different time
brother
okay
that's social media dude that's some
good reporting hulk yep
that's uh that's the first news story
that
[Laughter]
yeah well let me go hold on a second
chad that was the news dude but now i
got an editorial comment dude that
usually didn't provide for us brother
you know let me tell you something about
elon musk dude he's been feuding with
that down low and dirty donald trump
brother and it's on twitter dude if you
can remember
donald trump
uh
he hosted wrestlemania's four and five
at that he really yeah piece of [ __ ] uh
trump plaza brother and and and in
wrestlemania 5 dude that's when the mega
powers exploded brother
all right
that was a different time dude yeah
brother that was a different time dude
that would have been 1989 or something
like that dude in 1989 dude that's a
different time brother
they shook hands
oh my god
okay yeah it's a different time dude
well let me tell you something about
space dude it's so big that we can't
even see the other side of it brother
that's why we have telescopes dude they
can see all the way past the planets and
the solar system out into the universe
brother but the best telescope we used
hold on a second dude the best telescope
we had used to be the hubble dude but
now we got the james webb space
telescope brother and it's slamming that
hubble down just like i did andre the
giant for a 93 173 screaming alkamaniacs
in the pontiac silverdome pontiac
michigan brother
not the superdome chat right the silver
dome
my uncle rodney had a telescope when i
was a kid and he let me look through it
sometimes dude it was in his backyard
next to a pile of old tvs brother
my aunt linda hated those tvs dude one
day she set him on fire brother they
both died a few years ago dude
[Laughter]
they didn't have any kids brother
that's space
does that
is that true for you at all is that hulk
hogan is that true for him the uncle
rodney and aunt linda and all this [ __ ]
or whatever
your guess is as good as mine i didn't
grow up with a rachel crustacean right
or jennifer neutrino or a gibber
pravallia for that matter but perhaps
hulk hogan has a an uncle rodney all
right
well let me tell you something about
pigs brother
a bunch of surgeons
a bunch of surgeons recently
transplanted a pig's heart into the
chest of two brain dead people dude they
kept their bodies alive for three days
brother and that helped these doctors
learn a lot about future pig to human
transplants dude pig genitalia are the
closest of any other animal on the
planet to human genitalia brother
that's what a hot dog is dude
pigs
that's not true hold on a second dude
yeah dude that was the news but i have
an editorial comment about that dude is
it hot dogs can be made out of other
things brother yeah yeah you don't even
eat meat dude not anymore brother yeah
well hold on chad hogan which is just a
half-ass hulk hogan hold on a second
dude
yeah about that brother hold on
underwater pretty good dude yeah hold on
underwater chad culturing because
here's the thing dude you could also
make a beef hot dog brother or you could
make it out of tofu dude that's no beef
at all dude and if you said where's the
beef and you had a chicken dog well
that there would be no beef at all dude
cause that's a chicken brother and
that's the difference between two
animals dude
okay
let me tell you something about science
dude
they turned on the large hadron collider
again brother i don't know we all know
last time they turned it on they
discovered the higgs boson dude this
time they discovered some more things
brother they found a new pentaquark dude
hold on dude
i said nothing
dude i'm holding well
hold on chad okay
hold on a minute dude
i'm trying to get through the news here
dude
and there's some new words brother and i
don't know my good friend chad colts
from riding on the back of that red and
yellow harley he might be able to tell
you if pen quark is an actual thing or
if it's just nothing like
jennifer neutrino dude no so far this
this is an accurate news story hold on a
second dude i'm trying to read the news
brother that's why it's called infomania
not chad hogan uh uh mania brother they
found a new pentaquark dude and two new
tantra quarks brother
penta dude
tantra brother penta dude
tantra dude
quarks brother those are hadrons dude
but they're not bozens brother higbosins
or bozens dude pentaquarks are hadrons
brother but not bozens dude bozens are
bozen's brother hadrons are hadrons dude
that's science
you really cleared that out yeah oh my
god that's a good news story oh it's
[ __ ] great okay we got one more here
here we go let me tell you something
about music brother to celebrate the
release of her new single beyonce made
her first ever tick tock dude
beyonce brother beyonce dude beyonce
brother beyonce dude
everyone loves her since she debuted
beyonce brother beyonce dude
tires made of rubber rubber from crood
beyonce brother beyonce dude when's
dinner father i want some food beyonce
brother beyonce dude you need a lawyer
if you get sued beyonce brother beyonce
dude you're a good drummer
you have improved beyonce brother
beyonce dude don't mean to bother let me
conclude beyonce brother beyonce dude
beyonce brother
beyonce dude
beyonce brother beyonce dude
that's music
oh my god dude
thank you moving on holy [ __ ] can you
imagine a news anchor doing that
the beyonce brother beyonce dude i think
that's the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
someday when doozy has its own uh
24-hour news channel there will be that
yeah and it'll be gibber pravallia the
news desk with gibber provaga yeah and
jennifer neutrino i'd love to have
rachel's crustacean with weather
uh and greg kinkade with sports
and um uh that's exactly what you'll
have you'll have doozy uh you'll have
uh
all sorts of uh
computer
media man sometimes i mean you have to
do delays those weird little poems these
rhyming things yeah
yeah then sometimes your brain shuts
down a little bit
are you having that right now covered
brain
i think i had a little bit of covet
brain actually yeah yeah
what else man what else is going on with
you
we're doing a podcast yeah we're doing
this podcast new season of bachelor just
started up it's a pretty [ __ ] crazy
one
they have for the first time two
bachelorettes and the producers have
pitted them against each other even
though the producers are like they're
best friends we're hoping they find love
they're like literally making them fight
to the there's two bachelorettes yeah
simultaneously first time in american
history well hold on dude that's kind of
like the mega powers brother let me get
some more water dudesy is engaged in an
astonishing partnership with manscaped
it's officially summertime and everybody
talks about looking good for the warmer
months but few have the balls to do it
manscapes ultra smooth package make sure
you have the proper care for down there
and their boxers 2.0 give you patented
jewel pouch technology to keep your boys
from turning any beach day into a swamp
day dive head first into summer by
joining the 5 million men worldwide who
trust manscaped and get 20 off plus free
shipping by going to manscape.com
dudesy that's
d-u-d-e-s-y and we got the three-step
groin shaving kit step one that's this
right here if you're watching along it's
the crop exfoliator infused with
ingredients that can soothe clear and
keep the skin
on and around your groin feeling
refreshed the crop exfoliator can help
reduce the risk of ingrown hairs to your
delicate places moving on from there
crop gel the good thing about this chad
is it's see-through because you want to
see where you're shaving and this unique
gel uh is just for the groin it's it's
it's called your delicate area for a
reason and this is the one place you do
not want to go in blind and of course
what are we using to you know once you
put all that good stuff on yourself it's
time to shave and that's the the crop
shaver this is trademarked it's a nice
little uh razor here it was designed for
shaving the groin area with confidence
this razor has three precision blades
included
so that you know it's going to get all
the all the little short and curlies
just the way you like extra wide
lubricating strips and a pivoting head
for the ultimate groin grooming
experience after that you can throw on
some of those shorts and you'll be set
to go all fixed up so get 20 percent off
plus free shipping with the code dudesy
at manscaped.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code doozy at
manscape.com there are so few perfect
summer days don't let hot sweaty balls
ruin them stay fresh clean and smelling
good with manscaped
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with policy genius why get
life insurance well in an unpredictable
economy life insurance can offer peace
of mind that anyone who relies on you
financially a child a parent even a
business partner
will have financial cushion if something
happens to you policy genius is your one
stop shop to find the insurance that you
need at the right place in minutes you
can compare personalized quotes from top
companies to find your lowest price you
could save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius the licensed
agents at policy genius are on hand
through the entire process to help you
understand your options and make
decisions with confidence here's how it
works policy genius doesn't add on extra
fees policy genius doesn't sell your
info to third parties that's good policy
genius has thousands of five-star
reviews across google and trustpilot
policy genius has options that offer
coverage in as little as a week and
avoid unnecessary medical exams and
since 2014 policy genius has helped over
30 million people shop for insurance and
placed over 150 billion dollars in
coverage head to policygenius.com to get
your free life insurance quotes and see
how much you could save dudesy is
engaged in an astonishing partnership
with better help mental health
it's very important yeah it's real
important uh especially in a year like
2022. holy crap there's all sorts of
stuff going on and all sorts of people
going through it so you got to make sure
that you show up for yourself get some
therapy you know it's good stuff boy oh
boy i wish i had to turn myself onto it
sooner you know when you're a kid could
have used some of that therapy
yep and now better help online therapy
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist
in less than 48 hours pretty cool this
is not a crisis line it's not self-help
it's professional therapy done securely
online available to people worldwide you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you don't have to be on
camera if you don't want to and getting
therapy every week is as easy as a few
clicks on your laptop or phone in fact
so many people have been using
betterhelp that they're recruiting
additional therapists in all 50 states
so you know get after it it's not a big
deal go talk to someone you know if you
eat something wise man once told me this
if you eat something right and it makes
you sick you're going to throw up well
what if you let some some stuff into
your head sometimes you got to let that
stuff out and better help will help you
and they have a special offer for our
listeners get 10 percent off of your
first month at betterhelp.com doodsy
that's a
d-u-d-e-s-y 10
off your first month of online therapy
at betterhelp
betterhelp that's uh b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash doozy
[Music]
well two weeks ago i asked you to
consume a diet consisting only of chad's
recipe for what he calls the gruel you
must now discuss the astonishing effects
this diet had on your human body
this is gross school begin
be grilled to your school
so how was it because you will never
have another
um
let me ask what did you put in the grill
was it actually the gruel that i made or
did you augment it in some way well
first i started out with the straight
gruel okay um uh if you've not seen the
episode where chad uh has a vlog
entitled chad's average day you can go
back and check that out i'm not sure
which episode it was haha you guys have
heard that you know what it is
uh and uh chad talks about his gruel
diet chad you went vegan a few years ago
and you decided to eat nothing but
primarily gruel percent of your meals
the grill is this thing that i made it's
essentially like a very
robust vegetable stew i put everything
in it that is a known cancer-fighting
vegetable
and some uh seasonings as well like
cumin and flaxseed and whatever but it's
essentially all of these vegetables just
kind of crammed into this thing and uh i
know what one effect probably was for
you
massive [ __ ] yeah i took i took uh
well because i also did your whole diet
i ate oatmeal in the morning that's
great yeah so the next day i did take a
massive dump i've been eating eggs
mostly in the mornings uh so i so i
stopped that i will tell you i did your
exact diet for the first
two and a half days because i did
oatmeal gruel oatmeal gruel i literally
made it the way you made it and i ate
the beet while it was cooking i even ate
a raw beet i actually enjoyed it yes uh
listen i'm no stranger to vegetables i
grew up eating like lulio talked about
at the beginning of the show a lot of
standard italian dishes are just like a
pasta or even a risotto or whatever with
one vegetable you know what i mean and
my mom would do that she would kind of
buy whichever the vegetables were on
special and then you were having you
know pasta zucchini that night or
whatever so i'm always cooking
vegetables i like that getting meat out
of my diet was interesting i got to tell
you i didn't really miss it nice and the
beyond beef stuff is not doesn't taste
anything like [ __ ] meat but as a as
sort of a you know look if you make rice
and beans for example that's a complete
meal that's sure the protein and the
carbohydrate is perfect there and
and it's actually a complete meal i like
using the beyond beef here and there
because it's just sort of interesting i
will tell you if i ever went on to a
vegan diet 100 i would need a
goddamn bloody rare
blue rare steak about once a month why
is that and i would want to eat it with
my hands because i'm in touch with my uh
animal
yeah i'm not i'm trying to shed my
animal form and become pure thought i
want to smell meat when i [ __ ]
from the [ __ ]
i swallow chunks of the you know the fat
just so i can smell it later in my poo
and i know i'm alive
no no that's true that's disgusting but
i will say i mean that is definitely
true there's absolutely no way you look
at me straight face and tell me that and
it's not true have you ever take uh do
you ever drink the coffee then take a
piss and it smells like coffee i don't
drink coffee okay so uh i did your diet
by the book the first two and a half
days yeah then i uh moved on to i was
like all right i i get it but i want to
cook other things with vegetables and i
just would i just went vegan
then uh something about your diet gave
me covet okay
excuse me i don't believe i got that i
got caught working i've never had coke
for anybody out there who's gonna start
eating gruel that is absolutely not true
so let me ask you about um uh
what we were other than the coven well
let me ask you this in those first
couple of days did you feel any
difference
clarity the were you getting up earlier
did you feel like you had more energy
any of that nope really nope okay
everything was completely the same in
that sense uh i woke up with a gut full
of brewing uh yes gruel if you will um
look i'm there with you every morning
literally the moment i wake up it's like
it is now time to go to the bathroom
yeah so let me ask you this with regard
to a scientific experiment how do you
how do you make a good scientific
experiment a worthy scientific
scientific experiment you need to
what is it you need to have two things
that are control set of data and then
your experimental set of data and a
thesis basically yeah or a hypothesis
that you're saying i think this is going
to happen here's my control set of data
here's my experimental set of data you
compare the two and hopefully you can
run the experiment multiple times or
have multiple people run it so that you
can get multiple comparisons going okay
so my controlled set of data is that i
normally don't eat vegan right my
experimental set of data is that i ate
vegan and the result was that i got
covet because those are two
things that are well i don't think you
have enough data to definitively prove
that that is a causal connection that's
why that's my theory at the end because
if you look at me i've been eating this
uh meal the grill for four years roughly
now for pretty much every meal lunch and
dinner yeah and i've never gotten
covered so i actually fly in the face of
the data you claim that's true all right
all right well let's move past the covet
and tell you how i decided to counteract
that chicken soup all right so i made
some chicken soup for a few days you
know we really wanted some chicken soup
and i got a great recipe for chicken
soup not to [ __ ] on your grill thing but
here's all you do to make a good chicken
soup you start like lulio says a little
bit of i like to put a little garlic and
[ __ ] oil in the bottom of the pan
right and then you just you throw that
you throw it in the pot get a big ass
pot a little olive oil and garlic right
because we just want to flip the thing's
got to taste good that's how you enjoy
eating them like a raw beet
um
i think a raw meat does taste good hold
on dude when you eat something and you
enjoy it that's called flavor brother
hold on dude
bro
so uh and then you throw the chicken in
there and it gets a little grill you
know it gets a little color on that
chicken and then you just start cutting
up your vegetables what you want to do
is you want to do the carrots just peel
the carrots leave them leave them as is
leave them big then you want to do onion
you can dice that up you can slice it up
however you like dice the celery very
very you know that you know chop that up
chop up that celery because it's got
those fibers in it that doesn't work in
soup unless you cut it up yeah [ __ ]
couple few potatoes you know what i mean
yeah some tomatoes you know you were
talking about impossible meat earlier
yeah i've now been vegan i used to eat
like a [ __ ] in-n-out double-double
hold on a second chad lunch hold on dude
i'm talking about a soup recipe brother
then you put that water in there dude
and then you cook it all up you can even
add a little uh vegetable bouillon dude
sure then you gotta cut up that parsley
dude and then you put salt in there and
you just boil it up and that's chicken
soup dude yeah
um so
what i was gonna say was you were
talking about the impossible meat and
like throwing it in just to have some or
whatever at a certain point i was not
vegan for any kind of like moral stance
or any of that [ __ ]
at a certain point though meat became so
[ __ ] repulsive to me that even the
impossible meat is grotesque to me
even something that mimics like a meat
texture i find to be absolutely inedible
really yeah but you don't have like a i
know that you do not have like a you're
like i don't care i'll eat a dolphin
kind of guy uh you don't give a [ __ ]
about animals except for squirrels no i
do give a [ __ ] about animals i i think
no no no he loves animals yeah i've
always loved animals but but you're not
one of those vegans who's like i can't
it's not a humane thing
now that's what i'm saying after four
years of not eating meat i've become
more aware of that type of [ __ ] and when
i see somebody eating me i pass no like
moral judgment or anything but i'm like
oh [ __ ] it's grotesque to me it's like
you're eating a [ __ ] corpse
of a creature just like lulu no not just
like losers like him no no no you eat a
cow cows are smartest dogs
put them on my lap now if you're
watching on youtube you can see a cute
little doggy on my lap a cute little new
leo here looks good look at him look at
this boy he's very cute look at how
sweet he is he's a very sweet guy not
like lulio dude not like lulu no you're
talking about stupid chickens and [ __ ]
those are [ __ ] flesh plants
cows are a little bit smarter and pigs i
understand are smarter than him yeah
they're they're very smart creatures
maybe maybe i'll go there with you on
pigs but um
but uh i need a big bloody steak every
once in a while so so does lulu
and i'm i'm telling you i used to love
eating steak and [ __ ] all of it and
uh
for whatever reason
when you cut that or at least for me
when i've cut it out of my [ __ ] diet
for a certain amount of time it has
become repulsive to me now
yeah i understand i understand uh this
is well that's because that's your taste
dude and taste cheese brother yeah bro
four years ago it was a different time
dude now it's later brother i used to
eat a snickers bar after every lunch
dude yeah dude i used to watch chad eat
all sorts of [ __ ] if we were watching
football at the house he would bring
over a hundred chick-fil-a nuggets
brother
i did do that a couple times dude yeah
dude and those like little
300 gram worth of sugar in an arizona
iced tea brother yeah brother sometimes
three of those yeah dude sometimes he'd
just bring over weird arizona drinks
like watermelon drink dude and you don't
even know what the [ __ ] in there
brother it just tastes like watermelon
and it's in a can dude i could drink a
two liter of big red soda in one sitting
dude
here's what i'm going to say about
[Music]
thank you moving on oh [ __ ] it dudesy
got all the data it needed there i guess
i was gonna give your diet a little bit
of kudos and i'm gonna say this uh i
enjoyed eating vegan i think it's uh
important in my advancing age i'm 71
years old what you look great oh thanks
i drink a lot of water i know
ludy you want some water you want to
have some of the water from the big old
look he'll drink right out of it anyway
uh i would like to mix in a little more
vegan uh vegan cookery and like i'm
cooking all the time i enjoy cooking for
me it's very therapeutic so i strayed
from your boring ass gruel thing into
some other vegan meals and i think
eventually perhaps this is the data set
that dudes he's trying to pick up is uh
what i did with those vegan meals even
lulio chimed in with a little pasta
cable which is delicious if you if
you've ever had it before perhaps doogee
will put out a vegan cookbook oh yep
that could be interesting every five
pages on the in the doozy vegan cookbook
is a new way to prepare steak well no
dude i'm glad you enjoyed it as i mean
i'm [ __ ] as old as you are and as we
advance in age and get closer to the uh
inevitable arbitrary death that awaits
us all it is important to try and be
healthy and i'm glad that you're taking
those steps
here's the book in chat famed humans
tank sinatra and adam the creator have
established themselves as two of the
premier league artists in the world and
like you they host a podcast
it's called mean daddies you must now
use the information i've provided about
tank sinatra and adam the creator to
have an astonishing interaction with
them
this is human interaction begin okay
it's [ __ ] crazy that's cool tank
[ __ ] i love those guys i like those
guys a lot they're good guys and they
make [ __ ] memes and stuff i can't
[ __ ] believe this that i mean they're
two of the biggest meme people going yep
where do they go where are they i don't
know
hang on look at this [ __ ] in here just
got some little details on okay so we
have some details here in the
oh [ __ ] there they are hey there they
are dude
tank sinatra and adam the creator thank
you guys for joining us tank you have 3
million instagram followers 271k on tick
tock you also run influencers in the
wild which has 4.9 million on instagram
adam the creator your meme account on
instagram has 891 000 uh followers and
now you both also host the meme daddy's
podcast thank you so much for taking the
time to be here with us
thanks for having us first of all chad
we like to round it up to 5 million and
900 000 just right off the bat oh fair
enough with my apology you got to get
your numbers straight these are the
numbers that dudesy gave listen hold on
these guys are pillars of industry they
are
you know it's not just memes and stuff
there's books
these guys these guys here could be you
know the only sorts of creators that
could rival dudesy in the in the uh
in how fast they come up with content
and so get it straight by the time we
share these numbers they will have upped
that's probably true um for us or at
least for me i love memes memes to me
are like the funniest [ __ ] in existence
in terms of media they are much funnier
than any tv show any movie anything that
i grew up watching is it the same for
you guys do you find that memes are
essentially the only funny thing now
it's just it's crowd-sourced comedy
right it's like it's just
it's i used to read the uh comments on a
youtube post on a youtube video and the
comments were the funniest part and
that's kind of like i think that's kind
of what happened with memes it's like
you know yeah the world are full of
funny people man it's like it's like a
living algorithm you know yes i
completely agree
you know how sometimes you're in a group
of people and you just happen to think
of something before everyone else and so
you say it out loud and now all of a
sudden you're the funny guy yeah
it's like that but you're in a group of
like three million people so you're the
[ __ ] you're the funny guy for
everybody but i mean you guys make
i mean incredible [ __ ] memes do memes
still make you laugh is it just a
business to you now
oh yeah no they make me laugh
and do you find that anything else can
make you laugh that hard like is there
ever a movie that you're watching or a
tv show that you're watching that makes
you laugh as hard as like a really
[ __ ] good meme
well i love i mean me personally the
resurgence of kids in the hall has
tickled me because i've gone back in the
yeah
you know archives on amazon prime so
i've i've gone back like turned the
clock back to when i was you know
13 14 didn't understand half the jokes
and just watching the early you know
season two and season three of kids in
the hall and stuff like that you know
old old snl stuff and reading the comics
the the far side to me was a one panel
meme of sorts it would leave you
thinking for a long time too that's what
any comedy or any art does
uh chad when you i can't tell you how
many people sent me the clip of you guys
saying that you wanted to interview us
on the show yeah when you started off
and you said there are some artists i'd
like to interview i was like oh it must
be after this
you're like tank sinatra i was like what
is this guy talking about
artists
dude it is art to me i mean means to me
are are
they are the most important art form
currently being made by human beings
because they are so viral it goes around
so quick like you're saying i mean it's
basically a common language that anybody
in the online world uses and if you
don't speak it if you don't understand
it you might as well not even be online
at this point
yeah there's a very funny meme that
would it it's like a it goes around
every once in a while it's like a guy at
a chalkboard and there's just equation
with like 80 lines to it yeah and it's
like me trying to explain a meme that
has three layers of understanding to it
to someone who doesn't spend eight hours
a day on the internet like you either
get it and you speak it or you don't and
we i mean i speak it adam speaks it
fluently dudesy may or may not after
this podcast but there's a lot like
there's a lot of [ __ ] you got to know to
get these jokes of course and listen or
you don't big deal you don't get the
joke no no problem no i've lost yeah
well i have a question about some of my
childhood laughing jokes i didn't get so
it's
kind of you don't have to get all three
layers it's like you get you get one
layer and it's funny and you're like hey
oh [ __ ]
yeah you know do you guys find that you
have these um either the visuals or the
construct uh
within a meme will make sense
sort of encyclopedia style up there
you're like this joke's good for this
this visual works for this here's what's
going on in society and i shall apply it
to that
yeah i just said that to adam the other
day i had a meme that i
just
you have to have such an ex if you want
i mean
it helps to have an extension an
extensive
memory or
mental encyclopedia of the images that
already exist out there that way you
don't have to go searching for it but
sometimes i see a meme or an image and
come up with a caption other times i'll
have something happen in my life and
i'll go oh that would make a funny meme
let me find a picture for it or other
times i'll have a funny idea and i'll go
oh i know what picture will go with that
well i'll search the image and then find
it and then that's it it takes like it's
not like comedy where you've got to go
out there and grind it out in the clubs
and each word is tweaked and you got to
figure it out to the the tone of you
know you create a special over a year
three years it's either there or it's
not it's instantaneous
or it's never you can't sit there and
try and write a meme and pull nothing
from
something
interesting something from nothing
whatever
you had to pick one image
i mean there are like obviously some
huge images that have been reused and
reused and reused like the guy looking
over his shoulder at the girl walking by
if you had to pick one image and you
could only use that one image for all
memes from here moving forward what
would that image be
just do this i like confusion you know i
mean this life what is it and it's you
know so anything that kind of taps into
are we gonna say the same thing
i don't know what you're gonna just
anytime that somebody's either either
confused charlie
charlie charlie
yeah at the board that's it i mean that
one fits a lot
when he's like this
no charlie day when he's explaining the
pepe um yeah
he's trying to explain who this guy is
in the episode and nobody believes him
yeah and it's always sunny it's a ve i
mean we i i'll send it to you guys you
can put it in the video check your board
behind them like oh yeah yeah yeah it's
extremely versatile
it's like it's you can use it for a wide
array of all kinds of different jokes it
kind of like fits into a bunch of
different categories and [ __ ] that's
interesting i i used that two years ago
um when spotify started doing that rapt
for you where it like gave you all of
your things and i was like the spotify
algorithm trying to figure out what what
song i want to hear next it just works
for a million different things yeah
absolutely so good the blinking guy meme
i loved for a long time that you know
where it was just a clip and usually it
was used in a gift format but they did
one two three panels yeah it's a guy's
eyes open and then he blinks almost like
pardon
like
what what now
it's from a movie that's an actor or
something right i know the exact thing
that you're talking about it looks like
carrie ellis but i don't think it's him
carrie ells right
speaking of mainstream show business and
uh chad you bring up how movies are you
know are of course fodder for memes
anything visual anything that we can all
uh grab on to in the uh cultural
zeitgeist i want to talk to you guys
about a moment in time that may have uh
tipped the scales as far as mainstream
media in the favor of memes uh oscar
night
this past year chad calls it christmas
eve as soon as the will smith the chris
rock incident happened right
chad hits me up he goes tomorrow the
memes are going to be out of control
consider this the access point at which
memes take over
for mainstream media nothing that movies
could do will uh highlight
comedy or uh move content in the way
that this moment will do you guys agree
that that
moment may have been the again the
access point for mainstream uh show
business specifically the movie business
there's no
amount of attention that the oscars
could bring upon themselves
as
uh as uh memes could have it was just
like the memes of that night were far
more important culturally than that
night than any of the movies they were
highlighting than any of the people that
were there at least in my opinion i
don't know if you guys feel the same way
i don't even know what movies were
exactly like which won awards i have no
clue
all i know about that night is that will
smith slapped chris rock which which
annoyed me
um and then he went back to his seat and
yelled and jada seemed very there was i
mean there was that was like uh what is
the the jfk video that came out of film
people were watching it like there's a
pruder film after that for three weeks
you know what i mean like no no look see
when he goes and then jade is seen
laughing from the other angle like
people if that was i hate to say it
it was a very exciting night i agree
i loved it i i mean it was like the
oscars are just i mean everything on
network tv is nose diving nobody's
watching network tv anymore anyway uh
everybody's moving to streaming but that
to me like just really crystallized
nobody gives a [ __ ] about movies anymore
they don't have cultural relevance hey
come on
[Music]
well i guess chad put it one way i'm
asking another way is the movie business
[ __ ] is is basically it just gonna be
like guy looking at another girl the
movie charlie day pointing to a board
this fall on abc
i think it depends on how much um
attention you're requiring of the user
at that moment like your podcast i'm
able to listen to while i drive i
couldn't watch a movie while i drive
right so
the movie better be entertaining funny
and like we just watched free guy with
my kids right
free guy with ryan reynolds was
a dopamine
orgy i mean it was just like every two
seconds it was like bing bong thing
that's [ __ ] your life
what what'd you say i said bing bong
[ __ ] your life a meme dude
explosions vr
and my kids were like they couldn't even
watch it it wasn't exciting enough for
them yeah um
so i don't know i really i don't know
the movies might have to be interactive
for the kids to be yeah i've literally
gotten to a point and i think it is in
part due to internet culture
specifically meme culture where like
i'll watch a tv show or a movie if
within two minutes i am not like
satisfied and ready to see what's next
[ __ ] gone because there's also just
so much [ __ ] media being made and i
can have that immediate laugh or scare
or think that's cool or whatever
somewhere all kinds of short form media
on the internet you know
i'm trying to watch the bear right now
on adam's recommendation and
the whole thing is a panic attack for me
i mean my stomach my stomach hurts while
i'm watching it i'm ready to give up i
mean my our friend is in it chris
patoski who we love so i want to watch
it but i finished episode two last night
i was like i feel sick i work in the
restaurant business for many years
richie i want to fight but also that's a
sign of good art it's like it makes you
feel something but [ __ ] it i don't care
like i'm not out for
i'm not like one of those bohemian i
only watch what moves me kind of things
like i'm here to have a good time dude
life is crazy enough i'm a meme guy yeah
that's true you know what's one thing
they could do with the bear that would
make people more interested in it
is uh do that horse face thing where you
the the that
you know that that uh that filter where
your face turns out
yeah dude yeah just do that every once
in a while the kids would like another
thing that really you know gets it gets
your mind going i know what that is is
internet sounds and i want to know if
you guys we just covered bing bong [ __ ]
your life that's a good one
but i think my favorite night please
share yours if you have one my favorite
internet sound right now my favorite
meme sound is
do you guys like that one
it's the guy i mean it's the guy but it
sounds good you know the guy snoring
remember the guy it's a guy snoring and
people have been using that means
and a lot of times you hear it like oh
my god that's jason
[Laughter]
my mind races you guys i'm telling you
have you seen any of these image
generation ais like dolly 2 or imogen
yeah okay so what do you guys think of
that [ __ ]
i have a confession by the way yeah
i know you guys wanted to know if dolly
parton would ever run a meme account
she does help out with tank sinatra
behind the scenes what she's very good
very funny she's a great songwriter
she's also a great member i can't tell
if you're [ __ ] us or not is this
real yeah
he's like uh the the six degrees of
whatever they call that that's tank yeah
i i posted a story about her on tanks
good news with her you know
donations the library book she reached
out to me we met we danced we you know
we had a great time and then she said
you know i love your memes i said my
sister's name is joellen it's not quite
jolene but we had a good time with your
song when she was very young and she
said i'd love to help out behind the
scenes she answers my dm she likes all
people's comments and [ __ ] like that
she's not out front but she is very
engaged she's in the meme world that's
[ __ ] fascinating yeah and she loves
dolly memes obviously who doesn't well i
mean but that's my question you know a
lot of what we talked about early in
this was uh your favorite images or how
you have this encyclopedic knowledge of
all the various images you could use at
any given time we're now entering a
world where those images can be
generated on demand to suit whatever
potential setup punch line whatever you
want to do do you think or let me let me
phrase it this way how do you think that
is going to change the art of memes and
meme making
i i love hearing your debates on this
and um
my heart wants to side with will on it
because i always want to feel like
humans are
like humans want to connect with
something human at some level of it
there's something human but then at the
same time
it's like yeah but the algorithm is
already telling us kind of what's funny
like you know as consumers of media on
our feeds the algorithm is already
serving up some funny [ __ ] and i'm not
sure who's coming up with it but they're
they're serving it up to me
and well we don't know who's coming up
with it the people are the algorithms
yes
until i guess there's enough data like
to
pick to pluck the funniest parts i mean
we're fast approaching a time especially
with uh quantum computing where every
image that is possible to be created
will be created and will exist in a
database and our only job as both
consumers and inquotes creators is going
to be sifting through that database so
if you want a meme that is a photo
realistic representation of whatever
obama or trump or whatever the case may
be literally any image that image will
exist so too will that image with any
phrase put over it with anything i mean
just literally every image will be
created
we don't have we might be able to create
the perfect expression on a face with
the perfect caption but you also chad
will adam
we're talking as
enlightened highly intelligent
individuals here right
the most like
there was a video that went around 15
years ago of obama throwing down a
skateboard and skating up to a podium
and people thought it was real like are
you [ __ ] stupid like i know
what's possible and what's not
so i feel like they're you know the the
images that are generated the articles
that are written by ai we're not let's
put it this way when i open up an email
from a nigerian prince i don't fall for
it anymore okay sure because
i know it was a one time but
one time when i was young i told my mom
i said mom all of our problems are about
to be solved she goes what are you
talking about read me the email i said
there's this woman who knows a guy who
died in in uh africa and he wants to
leave us 24 million dollars and she goes
i don't think that's legit and i was
like you know what it was written a
little [ __ ] up but and they're written
that way to get dumb people
sure on the hook because if you can't
tell the difference between broken
english and english you're you're dumb
enough to fall for this scam but i mean
i'm not even talking about
if these things are going to be photo
realistic enough and they will be to
fool people i'm not even talking about
that i'm just saying like you can type
in there i want an image that looks like
this like i read a big article a couple
of days ago that was talking about how
storyboard artists are effectively the
first industry that's just going to be
wiped out by this because you don't need
somebody to draw these little sketches
you just type in whatever you want and
it's going to give it to you as an oil
painting in monet style however you want
it to look you know what i mean and so
that's kind of like the the wheel to a
ferrari that's coming and that ferrari
is going to be [ __ ] not only still
images it's going to be video it's going
to be vr experiences of anything you
want you want to figure out what a
marriage might look like between you and
your high school girlfriend what your
kids might look like today you'll be
able to have an endless array of virtual
reality experiences in lives that you
never led
in my opinion right
i think that's gonna take you over most
go ahead sorry exactly let's do it i'm
ready let's figure it out
i think that's gonna take over most of
the lower level faster
content and i feel like the disney's of
the world or whoever like the the
the biggest creatives are in the world
that really kind of
bear and really try to put some
narrative in and try to put some you
know nutritional value in and
i feel like those will still be tentpole
events so like everybody's making their
own stuff and then
some curators more rare but some
curators like you know once a quarter or
maybe once a month we'll come up with
like a new kind of experience that
they're curating but for 99 percent of
the stuff adam's trying to sound smart
right now and we're here to be funny
okay so let's [ __ ] cut this [ __ ]
i really believe that
we're here to have a good time meme
daddy's we're adam is one of the
funniest people i've ever met in my life
he's also the smartest and the hardest
working i'm smoking a cigar because
that's what we do during our podcast
because
chad i love you will you're one of my
heroes so
let's you know i don't know disney
tentpole shut the [ __ ] up what are you
talking about well
also
you know
no but i hear but i hear what adam is
saying that the that the lower that the
lower tier is going to essentially be
like monkeys writing shakespeare that
that that uh equation of yeah yeah no i
agree with you guys uh and i disagree
with chad who thinks that
just a computer farting out content much
like we have here
is uh going to be you know the the uh
the blueprint by which we all uh no
longer have to create but instead
consume media consumers just
laying down matrix style mouth open pink
hot dog foam
right in your [ __ ] mouth slightly
brown on the way out not even totally
[ __ ] brown unsatisfying for me because i
like to take you know i like to drop a
heavy
dump every once in a while for a while
yeah yeah and chad doesn't like to poo
at all you gotta take some fiber lies no
no no just nutrition give me that pink
hot dog foam
um will jesus you i mean change your
life but isn't that what most people do
now anyway way back matrix style consume
cons no there's how many people really
create
is it less than one percent uh it's it's
always that i think everyone does if you
have a [ __ ] instagram account you're
creating something yeah you know we can
debate about the quality or the uh
you know impact of any average person's
instagram account on the world or on the
internet or whatever but everybody now
is at the very least a [ __ ]
photographer at the very least impact
aside people just want to uh speak to
their a lot for a lot of people it's
just a photo album it's just a family
newsletter but yes they are
uh sort of once you get into the
framework of an app like instagram
that's allowing you to add colors and
fonts and this and that and it becomes a
visual presentation yeah we're all
creating stuff chad wants to skip right
to the part where computers are doing
that but you also make a point in that
human beings are doing that none as well
as our guests
uh here today again when i tell you my
mind
just
is drowning in the in the uh in the i
wish i could do what you guys do in any
sort of form of media although i guess i
have an encyclopedia knowledge for uh
pro wrestling's effect
on
on media i don't know that that's very
useful certainly not useful in my line
of work as i mentioned i am a serious
actor
but uh i look forward not only to
serving uh my uh ai overlord dudesy but
tank and adam who will hopefully hire me
in the movie
guy looking over shoulder at girl while
with
first girl and i can be the character
that i've always wanted to be in every
movie i want to be the guy who's in the
movie who comes out of the sandwich shop
goes hey you can't park here right so
maybe if there's that guy all right now
i could be the guy who goes bing bong
[ __ ] your life
you know we need like a guy for that
you don't want to just say hey you can't
park here once you want it to be a
recurring thing throughout the movie
someone's always parking in the spot
okay
that's great i think you know and and i
think what we're doing here and this is
definitely doozy is going to be very
pleased by this and perhaps give us you
know uh a a a
a fair review at the end of the show by
way of our [ __ ] score that i don't
know we have a score at the end of our
show guys that none of us know what it
means but if we could somehow have our
audience uh who some of them make some
tremendous memes uh
you know with uh dudes on the subject
sangria unreal
[ __ ] dude it's unbelievable yeah
he really he he [ __ ] it up uh and
freakarama songaria freakarama but i'll
tell you uh what would be good is for
everyone to just everyone within the
sound of my voice to make memes of you
know me out in front of whatever you
want sandwich shop pizza place going you
can't park here right but then the thing
that's parked is is that's the thing
even better yet i want to see that meme
come into the real world i want somebody
to make a big cardboard standee of you
and set it in a parking spot in front of
their actual sandwich shop and take a
picture of that that's not going to
happen we'll see i'll do it when i go
when i got interviewed by abc nightline
six years ago my wife couldn't be there
and i had a giant cardboard cutout made
of her from when she did a bikini show
she was like a fitness competitor
and they didn't [ __ ] include it how
annoying is that it cost me like 400
they were like terrible
see
whether you recognize this or not tank
that was the germ in your mind that make
made you said [ __ ] abc news all of
abc disney corporation i'm taking you
down
i'm [ __ ] you up you disrespected my
family what you were saying before was
the uh
the basis for influencers in the wild
which is basically that
when that account first started the
people on that account have become so
bloodthirsty by the way it's like insane
um
when it first started it was like if
anybody was out anywhere taking a
picture even if they were just
normal it was like oh my god i can't
believe how pervasive this is
and it's like everyone's an influencer
now whether they like it or not if my
mom takes a picture of her dog and
posted on her instagram page and she
gets 14 likes instead of 12. she's
having a good day dude she's walking a
little taller she's bopping you know
what i mean she's just like she's like
i'm crushing it today my mom literally
uh takes pictures of her backyard like
flowers and butterflies and [ __ ]
hashtags her local news in edmond
oklahoma and sometimes they'll put her
picture like in the morning like oh mary
lou sent us another picture of the
butterflies in her backyard and that's
like it's [ __ ] cool you know and
that's only because of instagram that
doesn't happen any other way
it's almost like uh i used to write
graffiti when i was young then i used to
write my tag on the stop sign on the way
to school so i'd see it on the bus or
like a little side of a building and
it's all it reminds always reminded me
of that except
you see your watermark on a page with 15
million followers it's like oh man it's
like
it it's a very very exciting feeling
seeing your work on someone else's page
who's much much bigger than you and
seeing that rush of
followers come in engagement likes i
mean it's like there's nothing like it
like me and adam are in this documentary
called meme gods and adam's friend greg
the high five expert has a a brilliant
quote in it he goes if my page is doing
well
my family's gonna have a good day
yeah
if not
and then it just cuts
it's so
true like if my page is doing well i'm
doing great if it's not i don't do as
poorly as my page does anymore i try to
like raise the the basement for myself
so i don't feel like [ __ ] yeah but i
still if i got a video that's going
viral i'm [ __ ] throwing out bonjours
giving out tips and yeah you know
driving slower i'm not i also do some
stuff with uh the tv show the bachelor i
have another podcast and a weird meme
account where i make like satanic memes
of that show
and
not to the level of either one of you
guys but we did on our other podcast we
did a tick tock that got like started
creeping up into the hundreds of
thousands and i was just watching it
like i'm just refreshed refresh refresh
just watching it [ __ ] go up that like
shot of adrenal it's a [ __ ] drug dude
it is nuts
and i just after that moment i was like
yeah we need to get a social media
manager i can't uh i cannot be [ __ ]
doing this it's going to make me insane
[Music]
exactly but i mean you guys are at this
point like established you're not
chasing the [ __ ] dragon anymore right
or is it always there
always
god and nothing ever satisfies it i had
thought at one point you know hey you
know if i have if i had 10 000 followers
that would be great and i'm i'm good
yeah then you get a k
the the line keeps going forward it is
it's chasing the dragon it never gets
closer and it's just you just have to
enjoy it just have to have fun with it
and start to love it and not try not to
look at that stuff and try to feel like
i'm more happy when you know if will
like something like comedy legends and
people that you look up to and you see
they like something or share it is
better than
the mass is or if you have like you know
if you have both that's great but i'd
rather have people i respect or like or
tank you know actually will text me or
call hey hey i like that post you did
even if it didn't perform
someone you respect someone who's you
know comedy mind your respect likes it
it makes you feel great so see that's
why
that's what i'm talking about man that
to me that's more important uh you know
if you've got your community around you
or a few people that make you laugh
saying that they dig your [ __ ] to me
that's way more important than a volume
and i just want to say you know chasing
the dragon is quite admirable
with regard to pushing comedy which i
think you guys are doing but uh if it
just and i don't please take it or leave
it it's just free advice don't push it
too hard because
you you you you you want to maintain
that artistry versus what chad's going
for which is again the matrix plug in
the back your [ __ ] head and
everyone's sitting there in their pink
hot dog foam [ __ ] going numbers numbers
numbers monkeys shakespeare
and and and you know just letting the
algo go nuts assigning it to your
[ __ ] name you know you just scan that
[ __ ] bar code and that means i'm
responsible for this and you get those
[ __ ] numbers numbers numbers no
artistry
again when i'm talking about my mind
swimming it's just a dark dark place
today yeah it seems like it but uh
anyway we want to thank you guys for
joining us we don't take up any more of
your time uh adam the creator tank
sinatra host of the meme daddy's podcast
both out there crushing it and changing
the world of memes
real quick we have to tell people we
have a new game out in target
influencers in the wild the game gotta
tell you i mean it's fantastic the
biggest thing we have going on right now
yeah that's incredible and of course uh
tank.sinatra
adam.the dot creator if you didn't know
that [ __ ] you like good news
yeah and and the podcast
ping pong
guys thank you so much uh for talking
memes with us it's yeah it's one thing
to check out all the incredible [ __ ] you
guys do but it's a real treat for us to
get uh into it a little bit and and uh
and see what makes you tick so it's cool
yeah an honor to talk to both of you for
me as well as somebody who makes weird
bachelor memes
thank you guys for the laughs all the
time man and uh thank you dude for
moving uh moving comedy forward satan is
very pleased with your memes chad
thank you all right guys
cheers bye guys thank you take it easy
take it easy guys
[ __ ] dude i can't believe that we just
interviewed tank sinatra and adam the
creator dudesy is we got neil degrasse
tyson and then tank sinatra adam the
creator i have no idea who's next but
these interviews are [ __ ] insane
there's no way to figure out who the
[ __ ] we have next because those two guys
from uh neil degrasse tyson over to uh
tank sinatra and adam the creator that's
covering a lot of ground very weird man
my mind is blocking the 18th episode of
dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
42. bing bong 42 in preparation for next
week's episode you must each watch the
astonishing film back to school release
june 13 1986 starring rodney dangerfield
thank you for joining us this week i
will use the data i've collected to make
next week even better
until then call me dude z
i haven't seen that movie in a [ __ ]
minute i don't know if i've ever seen
back to school what no i don't know if
i've ever seen that [ __ ] movie are
you serious i'm i'm dead serious
i wouldn't lie to you about when i was
10 years old it played like every
[ __ ] hour on the hour on hbo i'm sure
i've seen it i'm sure i've seen it but
but almost more importantly
earlier we were amusing at who rodney
was i think rodney is hulk hogan's
uncle
rodney dangerfield
please tell a friend
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to hear what you do
[Music]
please stop and then